Morning, Rebecca.
Good morning.
How are you?
Good morning. Good. How are you?
I'm good, thanks for asking. So unfortunately, Andrea is still on the meeting, so I'll be the one who's going to host the monthly business review.
In.
That's fine.
Hi, Joe.
Hey, Mark, how you doing?
Good, good, yourself? How's the vacation?
Good, good. It was nice. It was nice. Sorry for the delay. I was just speaking to one of our engineers.
Yeah.
Okay, so yeah, shall we start or are we waiting for someone? Okay, I'll just, all right, I'm gonna share my screen.
Yep.
I think we're good to go, Mark.
So here's our monthly business review for May 2026. Agenda, check-ins, highlights, action tracker, KPI analysis, and way forward. So first things first, highlights. So in regards to attendance, Jacob has been on an excellent attendance streak for the month of May.
So seems like he's doing a great job in terms of his attendance. So he's very dedicated to what he's doing so far. So which he did a great job. I've talked to him yesterday in regards to his performance with regards to that. So second one is in regards to productivity. Strong finish for the month of
May, with 241 tickets work on in total. And in regards to appreciation, he expressed the happiness that he has with the way he has been treated by MCG, genuinely well supported and
positive experience and assistance he has received from the team. So up to this day, he's very happy with the team, how he was taken care of and any concerns or issues that he raised, it was very taken care of. So there's no concerns in regards to that.
Next one is quarterly business review. So guys, I just want to ask, do you have any specific date and time for us to schedule a quarterly business review?
Like we just had one, didn't we just have one jumped?
Yeah, I would say I think, Mark, it just happened right before you joined. I think Andrea kind of let it or Andy let it. It was about, yeah, it was about last month. It was a little delayed, I think, because of the transition and stuff like that. So I think, I'm not sure if we're going to have it like.
Like last month, last month, right?
Okay.
I think we're good until like August, July, August, at least, yeah, August.
August.
Right, yeah, July, end of July, August, yeah.
Yeah.
All right, I'll go and take note of that. Thank you.
All right, so in regards to performance analysis, basically this is the utilization. This came from BrightGauge, Joe. So I'm using the BrightGauge now. Keep on tracking those utilization tracker for Jacob, which, great. So this data shows four week period for the month of May.
Okay.
Jacob maintained a strong, stable utilization performance throughout the month, having to, because the target is 80 percent, he basically almost meet that on the 3rd and 4th week. But it seems like there's a consistency in regards to the utilization that he has. So any inputs on this, Joe?
No, this is about where he normally is. And if I look at it closely too, it just pretty much averages out to 80% across four weeks.
Mhm.
Okay.
All right, next one is ticket closure trend and analysis. So as you can see from week one to week 4, it's quite high because the target that we have is only ticket 8 tickets closed per day. So the tickets that he worked on is pretty much high.
So Jacob demonstrated strong ticket resolution performance throughout the reporting period, achieving an overall average resolution rate of 86%, which exceeded the target resolution benchmark of 80%. The highlight of this report is there's a decline on week 3.
where the resolution rate dipped to 77%. But come week 4, where the resolution rate improved significantly for about 89% with 40 tickets closed out of 45. So he's doing a great job in terms of that.
Next is ITBD holiday, which is Independence Day, which Rebecca responded to me yesterday. So rest assured, like I mentioned, it will be coordinated to you guys two weeks prior or maybe a week or three weeks.
It has to be, it has to be at least, it has to be like 2 weeks, because I have to get people to cover then. And it's hard, especially on a Friday, to find people who want to cover. So I need at least two weeks notice, okay?
Mhm.
Okay.
All right, I'll take note of that. And then Jacob, he mentioned that he was going to target a certification this July for Azure certification, but he doesn't have any specific date yet, but he's trying to check those certifications on what he will take.
Thank you.
Yeah.
this July. So I'll update you guys in regards to that, the next review that we'll be doing. And then next one is continue progress on bright gauge discussion. So Joe, what's or when is our next?
It's.
Good.
Catch up for this.
So a couple things before we touch base on the right gauge, because I know that there's some nexus we need to take, especially regarding SLAs. The, just for reference for you, right, that first week in the month, he will have an uptick.
Yeah.
on tickets that are assigned and completed. That is also due to the scanning that happens. So you might see that on like the first week and maybe the 3rd or 4th week, because there's two times in a month that a full scan is done to devices in our Datto.
Mhm.
portal, when those occur, it generates tickets, right, based on alerts that it receives or, and those are basically tickets that he'll work on. And so for example, I think this past week there was about 27, there was a good amount of tickets created, I believe, not 27 exactly, but it was a good number of tickets created. And because they come in after hours, if Jacob has availability, he'll deal with those.
So that might see, that might be the reason why, more likely the reason why you see that huge jump in number of tickets signed and completed, usually that that first that first week of the month.
Mm.
Jump!
But does it include, does it include like the informational tickets? Like you mentioned that it will be going to be coming from the data portal, right? So is there any tickets like he'll just going to auto close? For example, the notification, is the data is already up to date or whatsoever?
like there's no need for him to troubleshoot or jump into a specific device.
And.
So the policy MCG with tickets right when it comes to a AV is that if it if the if the AV put it into a.
quarantined, then the ticket can be closed. And just made a note that it was reviewed and that the item was in the quarantine. That is the procedure that MCG has for AV alerts. But the way that the tickets are generated are actually through the data RMM. And so what happens is it's one ticket, but that one ticket may consist of.
Mhm.
for example, let's say 5 alerts, right? So the time spent is reviewing each alert and ensuring that the item was quarantined. And if it is not, then Jacob or any technician or engineer is then to take action to quarantine and ensure that the device is secured.
Okay, so there's a possibility that there's a specific or one ticket, but there's multiple devices on that specific ticket.
Not devices, there may be multiple alerts for the same device. So for example, I may pull up something for something small like, what do you call it, like on a PDF or something, where I may pick up something else on a file that was installed previously or in the drive or stuff like that. So all those alerts were generated for the same device.
Okay.
but under one ticket from that RMM.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Okay, so with that being said, I'm just going to wait for your update in regards to the discussion that we have for the BrightGauge SLA addition or modification that we're doing. So yeah, just send me a message. There's not going to be a problem.
Yes.
Yes, there.
PH.
Skill on to PC.
weeks or so.
Mhm, Okay.
And so I will reach out, you know, after that to, you know, engage with you on the KPI items that we discussed before. Regarding the Azure certifications, I am curious to just know which certifications he's going for in particular. If once he makes a decision on which certs he's going for, just let me know.
Sure.
I'd like to have a general understanding, and you know we'll go from there.
Yeah.
Sure.
Okay, and lastly, he just mentioned this yesterday when I talked to him that he'll take on the security awareness training and provide reports to responsible POCs he mentioned. So can you tell me about this for me to have a better understanding?
Sure, so we we we we do security awareness training for our clients, right? So, Know Before, Huntress are the kind of two biggest platforms that we use. However, we do custom reports for each client, and that is a process that actually are...
Mmh.
Our engineer, Joe Gonzalez, has been managing to now, and we are transitioning that from Joe Gonzalez to Jacob, but Jacob will also have a guy to go along with that. It's not just a transition of, like, you know, here are the steps and, you know, good luck.
Mm.
The goal is to make sure that he actually has a guide along with, you know, with the process that needs to be done. And he's also going to be, the first two months that he does it, he's going to be working directly with Joe to ensure that the reports are A, you know, obviously accurate, and B, that he's comfortable in the process and if any changes need to take place that, you know.
Hashtag splash.
Mhm.
You know, they're discussed before he, you know, flies solo on it.
Yeah, he also mentioned that yesterday that before he submits that to a specific POC, there's a go-to guy that's going to check it first, the report, before submitting it.
Yep, that would be Joe Gonzalez. Yep, he's good, he's good, he's running point on that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright, so yeah, in regards to Build It Live, is someone or somebody will gonna attend the Build It Live 2026?
Um, I'm going to say no at this time. I don't believe.
Thank you.
It was in August. Yeah, I don't believe we're going to be attending this year.
Kip.
But if that changes, Mark, I will make sure I reach out and, you know, try to coordinate something with you.
Okay.
All right, so yes, we're done. So any in particular guys that we want to cascade or you want guys to cascade to Jacob, like updates or changes in the process that you have in MCG that we need to discuss then?
No, I don't think so at this time.
Oh, thanks again.
Okay, so any questions so far in regards to the service revenue? Okay, so thank you so much guys for attending. Yeah.
No, things are good.
No, sir. Yep.
Yep, Mark, just an FYI, I did receive the monthly survey. I'll be filling it out shortly.
Okay, yeah, thank you. Thank you so much for that. I'm gonna wait for that. So yeah, again, guys, have a nice day and thanks so much for attending this call.
Yep.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you, Mark. Have a good day. Bye.
Ali.
Have a good one. Bye.